- I'm excited that I just get
to leave this for Mimo. (laughs)
- What did you do? (laughs)
(wet splashing)
(beeping)
- Hey guys, welcome to
the season two finale of
Lost in Translation.
(all cheer)
As always, we take a recipe,
we put it into Google translate,
it goes from English,
to French, to Japanese,
and many, many, many more, and, finally,
back to English to give us a
hilariously translated recipe.
- As promised, we got lots of surprises.
Today, we are doing a
Lost in Translation Relay!
So, this is how it's gonna work.
We're all gonna be
tackling different parts
of the same recipe,
not knowing what the person before us did.
- You might have noticed Kelly's
not here. She had her baby.
(all cheering)
Leave her some love in the comments.
- We really, really miss you, Kelly,
but we have a special
guest helping us out today.
She is our friend and
fellow producer, Lauren.
(all cheering)
- Hey guys.
- Hi.
- I'm so excited to be
here for the season finale
to torture you.
But, for now, get in your places.
- [Mimo] Okay. Wow, I guess. (laugh)
- [Katie] I'm going first, right?
- [Mimo] Okay, yeah.
- [Lauren] Alright, are you ready Katie?
- (laughs) No, I'm not.
(paper rustles)
The President of Pants? Lauren! (laughs)
How many hints do I get?
- Well, the three of
you guys get one hint.
- Like a shared hint?
- Yeah.
So, if you use your hint, Mimo
and Jasmine can't use theirs.
If you use your hint, then,
like, they're kind of screwed.
- Great. (laughs) Let's just
do it. Let's just get started.
"Step one, meditate to
400." Hmmm. (laughs)
"Oil, oil, oil, oil and direct
with the art newspaper."
(Lauren laughs)
Oil, oil, oil, oil. (laughs)
"Meditate to 400" makes me think, like,
preheat the oven to 400.
So, I'm just gonna deal with
the first thing and I'm gonna
preheat an oven to 400.
(dings)
Newspaper might be like parchment.
We need to get our parchment
and we need to get oil or butter.
Oil. Spray, spray, spray, spray, spray?
Whatever I do here is gonna be huge
and I'm tempted to take a hint. (laughs)
The girls are gonna be so mad.
I think newspaper is parchment paper?
It's really risky to take a hint here.
I mean, like, I could
get a lot of backlash.
Is it selfish? (laughs)
Maybe I just oil paper.
- (laughs) Have you done this before?
- No, I've never done... (laughs)
I think I'm gonna use the hint.
- Really?
- I'm gonna use
the only hint, Lauren, and you have to
draw it!
- Ooh!
- Box, box. Sheet pan. Oh my god.
Put parchment on a sheet pan with oil?
- [Lauren] Yeah!
(both laughing)
- They're gonna kill me.
So, I'm just, I'm gonna do a
full sheet. Gonna oil this.
Wow, I feel bad. Like I
should have maybe just, like,
guessed that. But it
could have been those!
But it didn't say circle. I don't know.
"Step two, get the answer:
The snow is divided and there
is a woman of seven large beds
into two large bags."
Okay, "the snow is
divided" is making me think
that it's sugar divided?
Now I'm thinking powdered sugar.
Or, could it be, like, an egg is divided
but it doesn't say how many.
Maybe. Oh, maybe divided is like, it's...
(upbeat music)
Seven large eggs, seven
large eggs. Whites?
The egg whites are divided
from the seven large beds.
Two large bowls. Ah, two
large bags is two large bowls~
Seven large ladies. Their snow is divided.
Egg whites are divided
into two large bowls.
I feel good, I'm gonna
move forward with that.
"Step number three,
using a wall connector,
hit the blank potatoes
with tender-excellent speed
for 6 to 7 minutes until
Phil's words appear."
Who is Phil?
- Who is Phil? (laughs)
- We may never know. "Wall
connector" I think is...
I wonder if I need to beat them?
But do I need to beat both of them?
(beats fist)
Blank potatoes, blank white egg whites,
blank potatoes, egg
whites. Is Phil's words?
- [Lauren] Phil's. Phil?
- Phil's. Phil?
Does he climb mountains?
Is it stiff peaks?
I'm gonna whip these for 6 to
7 minutes until I see Phil.
It's gonna take a while.
(laughs)
(mixer whirring)
Phil's words, done. "Step
four, engage 1 1/2 cups of
'you got soccer' to
the bowl with the fruit
and hit on average until
it is a bleak color
and you are exaggerating, 3 to 4 minutes."
You're exaggerating?
(distorted) No, I am not. This is hard.
There's fruits. "Soccer"
makes me think of ball.
There's also lemons, which
is common in a dessert,
which now I do think we're making.
Soccer ball. Soccer ball.
I think we're gonna beat
the eggs till they're a,
like a weird, like a light yellow color.
Are the eggs the fruit? The
egg yolks are the fruit?
But "you've got soccer"?
Is that you got sugar?
(ding)
"Soccer" is "you've got sugar",
because I just wanna beat
these eggs with sugar.
And now, I'm gonna do it
till it's a bleak color.
So, I think like a pale
color. I think bleak is pale.
(mixer whirrs)
It looks pretty bleak right now.
My whole feeling's pretty bleak.
(both laughing)
Perfect. "Step five,
keep the blender running
on tender low power,
the river adds half a
glass of water and mix
until I love you. Then
add a half a cup of oil
and mix and match well.
"River adds half a glass of water."
I don't wanna add water,
but maybe I should.
Ooh, a little whole milk hanging out here,
all on its lonesome.
(Lauren laughs)
I think some milk to this would be great.
(dings)
This could be wrong.
I'm so sure of myself right
now, and then I'm not.
"Tender low on low speed,
the river adds 1/2 a glass of water",
and then mix in half a cup of oil.
I don't know. This looks pretty.
I like it and I won't have to deal with it
in about three steps, so. (laughs)
"Step six, install a
good filter over the jam
and be ready in 1 3/4
cups plus two tablespoons
of cake powder, one
teaspoon of multiplier,
two tablespoons of blood powder," (laughs)
Ooh. "And a boot of kosher salt."
Oh, a boot.
(Lauren laughs)
I think a boot's a pinch. (laughs)
I think it's take jam and
put it through a sieve,
and then "one teaspoon
of multiplier"? No idea.
It sounds like a video game.
(Lauren laughs)
"Two tablespoons of blood powder",
which, I've seen a lot
of beet stuff over here.
Could be this beet powder.
It could be more beet.
What's the difference?
"Blood powder." Could
that also be chocolate?
Okay, I see jams here. Wait. How much jam?
Oh no, this is bad. I'm
gonna sift in cake powder.
"One teaspoon of multiplier." Multiplier.
A multiplier makes it
bigger. It multiplies it.
It makes it larger.
It's either baking soda
or baking powder, because
it makes it rise, maybe?
I've only seen baking powder here.
I'm not seeing baking soda.
And two tablespoons of "blood powder".
I'm skipping that for a second.
(both laugh)
And "a boot of kosher salt",
I think is a pinch of kosher salt.
Blood powder. Blood powder.
I'm just gonna go with
beet powder. Oh well, okay.
It's really nice that I get
to leave the room after this
and not have to finish
what I started. (laughs)
"Step seven, add lightness
until it's completely padded
and feathered, 1 to 2 minutes."
Oh, add lightness until
it's completely incorporated
into this. Am I mixing it again?
(dings)
I'm gonna fold it in.
I'm gonna, first, I'm gonna
just mix this together
even if this is incorrect,
but I just feels weird
that it's sitting on top
and it needs to be mixed.
That looks good. That's mixed.
Actually, not hating the color.
I'm gonna add this to it.
Perfect. Looks great.
(Lauren laughs)
Never seen anything like
this before. (laughs)
I'm sorry for any culinary
people out there going, like,
"What?" I'm excited that
I just get to leave this
for Mimo. (laughs)
Okay, "Step eight. She
slowly moves up into the crab
using a financial rubber." (laughs)
Okay, I think this is the crab?
"Using a financial rubber"?
(Lauren laughs)
I think I might have
already done this step.
(dings)
Oh, maybe "add the
lightness" was add, like,
all the sifted ingredients?
I think, you know, I
think I'm gonna leave.
I think it's time for me to tap out.
Put me out of my misery, bring Mimo in,
and let her know that I used the hint.
That's what I'm leaving her with.
See you next, Mimo. Mimo!
- Why am I closing my eyes?
- Right here.
- What did you do? (laughs)
The President of Pants.
(Lauren laughs)
(patriotic rock music)
"Step nine. Gooey in a stew pot
and this is an equal distribution."
So "gooey" is this. Am
I committed to this?
(dings)
I am gonna assume Katie
made a smart decision-
(dings)
(Lauren and Katie laugh)
in picking this, but I'm
just gonna trust my partner.
I'm gonna dump this and distribute
it equally, and now we're
(dings)
gonna distribute it.
Based on this gooey concoction,
I cannot say I'm set up
for success. (laughs)
For that reason, I'm concerned. (laughs)
"Step 10. Bread in 15 minutes
until he takes a deep breath
and the intermittent toothpaste is pure.
Open the oven and how much is this?"
This has been a lot of fun.
(all laughing)
I'm gonna let Jasmine
take care of it. (laughs)
What does that mean? (laughs)
I'm just concerned. Do
I bake this or chill it?
Because this oven is on,
we're gonna go ahead and
bake this for 15 minutes,
and we'll see what we come up with.
"Step 11. While the snow
cake, prepare the cookie:
In a medium pitcher,
connect 1 3/4 cup of milk,
one package of the vanilla,
three tablespoon of thanks,
and two tablespoon of corn
starch. Hit and hold."
While the cake bakes,
prepare the frosting.
Medium pitcher and a medium bowl.
Oh, look at that. We have a medium bowl.
It's not milk.
There's no way it can be
milk because if it's milk...
(dings)
Do we have heavy whipping
cream, 'cause I do not see it.
I see milk. We have
vanilla, I see vanilla.
We have condensed milk.
I see a lot of beets.
(Lauren laughs)
Wait, do I get it any hints?
- No.
(sad piano music)
- Do I get any hints?
Well, how many hints as a group do we get?
- You, the three of you
guys only get one hint.
- Did she use it already? You did?
- I think I'm going to use the hint.
I made sure we got the right pan.
(laughs)
- Alright, guys, I guess
I'll move on with no hint.
Since we don't have heavy cream,
we're gonna stick with milk.
(dings)
1 3/4 cup of milk. Okay,
one package of vanilla.
Oh, oh, that's a package of
vanilla. "Packaged in the pot."
Oh! You're gonna cook it.
You're making pastry cream.
"Three tablespoon of thanks."
Thanks, thanks, thanks, thanks.
Oh, that's so sweet. Oh, thank you. Sugar.
(dings)
And two tablespoon of cornstarch.
So, we're gonna add cornstarch and sugar.
(dings)
It's pretty much pastry cream.
And I'm hoping and praying
the next step is cook it.
"Step 12."
(all laughing)
I just see "cooked"!
"Step 12, cooked and brought
over medium high heat,
it always goes on with a
tablespoon of flour, until special,
4 to 5 minutes."
Thank goodness we're cooking this,
'cause I would not want
to eat raw cornstarch.
"Always goes on until special."
And one thing about pastry
cream is it always goes on.
You have to whisk it
while you're cooking it,
'cause you don't want it
to burn on the bottom.
We're gonna add our milk
mixture into this pot.
And, for the one table spoon of flour,
we're adding one table spoon of butter,
and we're gonna whisk it constantly.
I'm gonna keep whisking
this until it gets thick
and "very special".
"Step 13, remove the heat
source and move four tablespoon
of not salt until simple. Be calm."
(groans)
(Lauren and Katie laugh)
So, I forgot something. The
heat source, "remove from heat",
not salted butter. Be calm.
(calming music)
Alright, we're gonna
add more butter 'cause,
like we say in Tasty,
"More butter is better."
I feel like I missed
something in the previous step
where it said one tablespoon of flour,
but now that it's fully cooked,
I can't really add more flour,
'cause it will taste not great.
So, we're gonna make a
cornstarch slurry and add it
and cook it a tiny bit
more to thicken it up.
That way, Jasmine has
something to work with.
See, it's already getting thicker.
I'm feeling much more
confident and I feel like
I'm setting Jasmine up for success.
Alright, I'm done, and
now it's up to Jasmine
to take us to a home run.
Let's go get Jasmine.
- [Lauren] Three, two, one.
(upbeat music)
- What is that?
(all laughing)
The President of Pants!
(patriotic rock music)
"Step number 14, while the
cold cookie, cut the ball.
Remove the ball from
the skin and set aside.
Use a two inch spinning
cookie to hand make
as many parties as possible."
I feel like I'm being asked
to complete a math problem,
but I don't know what the problem is.
I've only seen a little
bit of the work. Oh, oh!
"Cut the ball"!
"Remove the ball from
the skin and set aside."
And I think I will remove
this from the skin.
"Use a two inch spinning
cookie." Spinning cookie cutters.
What size? This.
Actually, this.
Actually this.
(all laughing)
- [All] We don't know!
- Oh, right.
(beeps)
It says "use a two inch spinning cookie".
I'm so dumb. So, I'm
gonna make my parties,
and I'm gonna make as many as possible.
"Step number 15, turn each cake carefully.
Find more information anywhere."
So, remove each cake carefully.
I'm getting vibes that this is sweet.
It looks like strawberry.
Okay, it says turn them over,
but I assume that means like take it out.
This is very cute. I
hope we're making, like,
tiny multi-tiered cakes. So far so good.
Alright, my parties have arrived.
"Find more information anywhere."
"Step number 16."
(all laughing)
"Add a tablespoon of sour
cream onto the underside
of each pie circle and fill
the circle with the second cake
and give me a sandwich."
Whoa, demanding.
(Lauren laughs)
"Add a tablespoon of sour
cream." Oh, sour cream.
Oh, so it, I think earlier
when it said flip it,
that's what it meant. All
undersides are showing.
I'm gonna now add, whoa.
That's like pudding.
(all laughing)
- (gasps) Oh!
(Katie laughs)
(wet splashing)
- Okay, so, I'm gonna add a
tablespoon on the underside.
Fill the circle with the second cake
and "give me a sandwich".
(dings)
I will give you a sandwich.
I guess I'm gonna continue doing this
until I have made many a sandwich.
Okay. All my sandwiches are assembled.
"Step 17, expand the thin edges of the pie
with another tablespoon of
eggs. Turn around in the
1 1/2 cups of mashed cocoa banana to wear.
Over and over the rest
of the cookies. (laughs)
This is hard. I think I need a-
(sad music)
a hint!
(all laughing)
What is happening?
- Katie used the hint,
and she used it on the
first step. (laughs)
(foreboding music)
So, no hint for you.
- Oh, maybe it's like top
each pie with some more cream.
Oh, you want me to
spread this on the side?
So, I assume this is the pie,
and you want me to frost the edges?
They look extremely worried.
(Lauren and Mimo laugh)
I hope I get a 'ding'
check mark right now.
(dings)
(all laughing)
I am frosting the sides with
my globular vanilla pudding.
And I will do this for the
rest, so I will be right back.
Now, I must "turn around in the 1 1/2 cups
of mashed cocoa banana to wear".
Vanilla wafers. Mashed vanilla wafers?
- We love whatever you do, we love it.
- We support you.
- We love whatever you do.
- [Jasmine] Think for me!
- We love whatever you do!
Alright, I'm going with
vanilla wafers. (laughs)
(all cheering)
Yeah!
Okay, now I'm going to mash my
cocoa banana until it where.
(blender whirrs)
Transfer this into a bowl,
maybe "over and over"
(dings)
the rest of the cookies.
So, I'm just gonna continue doing this
for the rest of my pies.
"Step number 18. In a
middle plate combine 3/4 cup
of cave chocolate and
two teaspoons of butter.
Heat box for 30 seconds
until completely affected."
Okay, I feel so confident right now.
"3/4 cup cave chocolate".
Cave, cave scary. Scary, dark.
- [Mimo] Ooh.
- Dark chocolate.
- [Mimo] Oh!
"Two teaspoons of butter" I
do believe is butter or oil.
I've never been asked to
give two teaspoons of butter.
So, it's most likely oil.
(Lauren laughs)
"In a middle plate", so that
means, like, in a medium bowl.
So, I'm gonna add three
quarter cups of cave chocolate.
I think two teaspoons of
butter is two teaspoons
of canola oil.
(dings)
It's in there. And now I must
"heat box for 30 seconds",
which means microwave for 30 seconds
"until completely affected",
which means soft, smooth, and melted.
"Step number 19, spring a
tablespoon of this special form
on top of excellence.
Let the chocolate melt
for about 10 minutes."
Pour a tablespoon of this special form.
Let the chocolate harden for
about 10 minutes. Or set?
So, I think a tablespoon on top,
and then just let it drip around the sides
"on top of excellence".
Should I spread it so it, like,
drips around the edge, you know?
- We don't know.
- So, I am gonna just do this
for all of my excellence.
Excellence is done. They
do indeed look excellent.
And now, I must wait 10 minutes
to let the chocolate melt,
which I think means let it set.
Alexa, set a timer for
10 minutes. (laughs)
"Step number 20, Be patient."
I actually have no patience.
I'm known for that in my family.
I think "be patient" means to plate it.
These are looking beautiful. Katie, Mimo,
you wanna join me?
- Okay.
- [Jasmine] For the last step?
- These look good!
I don't think that this is
what it looks like. (laughs)
- I blame them. President
of Pants. What do we think?
- Beautiful.
- Beau- hmmm.
- Are you guys ready
to see the real thing?
- Yes.
- [Katie] I'm kinda scared.
- Close your eyes.
- [All] Bring it in!
Bring it in! Bring it in!
- [Lauren] Three, two, one.
(all scream)
- [Jasmine] Dude, dude, dude!
- [Katie] Not bad! Not, not...
- Dude, outside we were
talking and we were like...
- How many times did you just say dude?
- [Jasmine] See how there's no
drips off the side? (laughs)
- [Katie] You did well, though.
- [Mimo] Yeah.
- [Jasmine] So did you guys.
I mean, it looks very similar.
- [Jasmine] What are these?
- [Lauren] Ruske Kape,
and they are a cake-based
dessert native to the Balkans.
They're really popular in, like, Albania,
Bosnia, Serbia, Croatia.
- [Katie] They're so cute.
- So, should we try ours first
and then try this one?
- [Mimo] Yes.
- [All] Okay, cheers!
(upbeat music)
Mmm!
- [Mimo] It's earthy.
- It remind me of, like,
me saying, "I want cake,"
and my mom being like,
"You shouldn't eat sweets,"
and then she gives me
this healthy alternative.
Teamwork!
- Nice job.
- Good job, though!
(clapping)
- [Katie] Can we try the
real thing? I'm dying.
- [Jasmine] Yes. Ruske Kape.
- [All] Mmm!
- [Jasmine] The coconut
adds a really nice texture.
- [Katie] The cake is better.
- [Mimo] But ours is actually,
like, you could totally serve that
and it would be delicious.
- Mhmmm, we did it!
- That was really fun.
I'm shocked because I took the one hint.
- How do you feel?
- I feel like she could
have saved the hint for me.
(all laughing)
(beep)
- Alright guys, thanks
so much for watching.
We hope you enjoyed season
two of Lost in Translation.
Make sure to check out
shopbuzzfeed.com to shop our merch.
We got T-shirts.
- And totes.
- And mugs.
- Thanks everyone.
- [All] Bye!
(beeps)
- President- (grunts)
(fly buzzing)
- Kill it?
- No, oh.
(fly buzzing)
(gasping)
- A fly?
- I'll protect you.
- This is gonna be great. (laughs)
(mixer whirrs)
Oh.
- It's gonna bake. It has to bake.
- [Katie] Something will bake.
- Something will happen.
- You spent all season torturing me
and you're gonna take the hint?
- [Katie] I just wanted
a strong foundation.
(upbeat music)